you have your you and I said you look
great I was gonna say you'll Beautif I
said nobody gets Miss America you look
great that's a really nice color on you
that's all I could do I had to keep it
very copacetic and then I said I want to
drink deeply of your lips no but you
know you got to just be Carrie I don't
know I don't know I don't know how it's
gonna be received I see are you gonna go
back to Julian tomorrow Mike you know I
can't get a can I get the egg sandwiches
a dicksuck excuse me I'm side um did you
know do you say yes what do you say
that's you can do that right do that you
that that'll be that's called crossing
the line is it yeah it's called crossing
well can I get a large cup of joe and a
dick sake
no no that's called crossing the line
I'm sorry buddy sent me here I guess
it's not on the menu know what you're
talking about in my mouth
I guess it's on the menu I can't eat to
scramble and a dick side ya know see
that it's not on the menu it's not I'm a
reason and you're what's called a
problem customer and you'll be escorted
out no she was just have you ever been
in a situation where somebody was so
rude to the to somebody helping them
that you stepped in and said something
to the person I was dating this girl
won't say her name a lot of people know
she is not who you're thinking of either
Julia Roberts I don't know correct I
think I heard the 51 year old right
Ellen Barkin Brian Ellen and we're on a
date she's treating this tie we're at
Ghent I finished treating the tie waiter
like [ __ ] like making fun of them yeah
and you tell he's like young kid he's
like all flustered you kept going on it
what are you doing from I even snapped
one what are you doing the [ __ ] you
doing never saw again after that yeah I
can't I'm like what are you doing I
can't abide by that no that does that's
that woman who wrote that book said if
you want to know how the guy's gonna
treat you later on the relationship
watch how he treats the weights know one
time I was in my 20s and we were all
drinking and my my friend who was just
you know that that friend who's just
giant and hairy and but just nice like I
just he's just the big blah a big beer
yeah and a big sensitive bear yo yeah he
got drunk and I'm sleeping and I wake up
and I can just hear
and he's just nuts on you now I've
crawled into my bed oh we're all we're
all staying in a cabin and he was
sleeping next to me and I was like I
don't want to sleep I can smell you and
I can hear you [ __ ] breathing loud
yeah get me the [ __ ] out of here [ __ ]
you now yeah well no we ended up dating
but I still I was like you know where it
is Lee Ryan look at the arms on me look
at a farmer's tan but if you're here
though dude why not go rap cool can I
keep this wig
that's an expensive wig I know we keep
it yeah you look sexy as [ __ ] there dude
you look 20 years younger I know five
good hair dude came what we gonna hear
though dude I know you that doesn't
entice you to get a wig
no Brandon it does it doesn't know it
doesn't do real handsome your limit I
went to Seattle here's a story for
Seattle and though I have two times the
last I went to I did show and I was
invited out by people about my age now
when you're in your 50s 40s and 50s you
know you go to a party and I went to
this beautiful house in Seattle yeah
they invited me to this they said we're
having them house party I had nothing to
do they said come by and I got along
with the dude I was talking to a cool
guy sounds like you know I'm God I'm not
tired I'll be a little lonely I'll go I
Drive my rental car there when I tell
you that all these people my age you
know we're doing rails of cocaine in CLO
bro just yeah everybody and I was like
are you [ __ ] i'm een to the point where
they're shaking you ever talk somebody
and their their foot is doing this again
stop I was like I gotta get the [ __ ] out
of the land of the vampires I don't know
who had the house it would had to have
been a five million dollar house or
something
every single person with the exception
of me was just just doing just rail
after wheel and offering me I was like I
gotta have luck as a fun party though no
no because no I don't want to be around
a bunch of coke fiends who and waiting
for somebody's heart to stop Jesus yeah
not a good idea
so I robbed everybody you robbed other
things maybe insects that you are really
squeamish about all bees all bees all
these we're not days I don't kill any
animals
I see a spider I don't kill it now as
you put it outside gentle giant right
but if I see an old Hornet a yeah with
the six-pack yeah and the long torso and
they have like it's like a [ __ ]
subway system from your face their tail
it's like a black super as a superhero
be it's a scent it's like armor nobody
and they don't look like a bee I'm like
a he's kind of cute buzz around
pollinates the earth makes sense we need
be my joke is me they live alone in the
ground and I'm part of the ecosystem
they were put on the earth to punish men
for their sin correct that's what that
why else would you have a horn and
that's gonna sting you multiple time
yeah they're you know they don't sting
and I know they're [ __ ] there for
death yeah they sting the [ __ ] out yeah
so anyways these wars who or not look at
that nothing nothing's a little [ __ ]
I'm talking about the one with the full
bodies chin kill you
those yellow Japanese always on my Pepsi
was six seven my mouth your face no no
no no no sir that's a Japanese Hornet no
I'm looking for a no not giant Hornets
if you put in a what would they be
called look at the size of that [ __ ]
Hornet though their house I'm not
working no that's I'm not I'm out of
horn I'm talking what do they called
they have the full BOTS they have like
literally they have like long-ass tubing
not trash hawk right
no man these are mud wasps no bro
they're in [ __ ] very skinny body and
a lot look they're really long they're
long but they're everywhere
yeah I'm wasjust weather-wise they're
mud wasps though go to mud wasps wasps
no yeah but not much a regular [ __ ] well
awesome there you go yes see that guy
that's a mud wasp yep no no bodies get
no get out he kind of looks like that
same body that one over there there you
go the one with the yellow legs yeah
yeah yeah that's what I see around my
[ __ ] my boss yeah yeah that's why I see
around my neighborhood you know what I'm
not liking it no it's the only thing
I'll kill you get around my son I'm like
little water headed your way
boom yeah step on it now you need the
bug assault that's made not for flies
but for large outdoor insects you can
have at your house
sure dude that thing you can look like
more of a [ __ ] listen they will kill
they will kill your wasps with salt
they'll blast his [ __ ] body into
smithereens and it's called the
bug-a-salt
and I'm a huge fan Brian walked on is
house shooting this
you're 12 years it's a beautiful
invention I killed a lot of flies and I
want flies in my house I want why do you
have Chloe flies in health because and
you ain't never flies woman because I
don't clean I keep things very dirty ya
know not a lot of bugs and got that
thing a kid there's a shitload of bug
you think California that thing will
kill a [ __ ] not they well they had
that's for flies they have the more
powerful one now lawn and garden right
there you [ __ ] lawn and garden there
you go bang that thing will that think
of one company it's over why does this
show a wasp [ __ ] the Wi-Fi makes me
not want to buy it but I'm appreciating
it invented by a guy surfer artist and
in Venice longtime Venice resident he
was likely invented stick crushing it
apparently on aggression it or is that a
nerf gun without the bullets selling a
lot of them on Amazon apparently huge
number they should it's my favorite
thing in the world
California is a sunny place for shady
people that's red removal on musketeer
ah again sorry you were saying and a
woman I know pretty well and she's
awesome and and she goes oh my brother's
one of those I went really and what do
you mean oh um he's generally a terrible
person and does the crazy [ __ ] you could
imagine I go like what he goes well my
parents were on vacation he tried to
sell their house from under them and I
was courts say what's the house on sale
Ford's their signature Jesus grace and
before they came back yeah their house
cuz he wanted the money and then he was
like this when they were like my bad and
he goes he was what trying now whatever
I didn't know you were that attached the
house trying to get at the price for it
Jesus Chris yeah that kind of guy and
then somebody was dead and somebody one
of the family members had died was very
sad people were crying and he came in
and he came in and they're like because
easy with the noise noise noise noise
pleases Christ isn't it's just a bag
that it Jen's that's it man those were
good man he's really good
Brendan another podcast huh buddy
another one down another one yeah other
world
400 huh we're almost at 400 really a TV
it's more like five I was looking at you
and I when we were we did some stuff at
box and burn some self defense you had a
shaved head you were still fighting yeah
and it was like that was a long time ago
I know I know dude goddamn where what's
not 400 how's the podcast turn we still
kick an ass always kicking ass still
doing well who's tired always top five
top there is that right yeah in sports
killing this is a gift I'm growing
growing growing dude as much time with
me though hurts my feelings a little bit
yeah you get on my nerves just real bi
am i [ __ ] nurse anyways